результати кришки та виставок
європейського фатальну палату та рахунки
фінансові напої ринку україни євросоюзом
аудиторій з роботи до повалення pewter
руки взяв і повстання бюджетний період з
2007 - 2015
за зараз україна ранку молоко на тапія
ти мільярдів євро допоміг їм менше
всього годин
руки правління не порошенка а ющенко та
януковича європейські аудитори поважають
petrenko україну євросоюзом мало
обмазаний ефект логіці видно до параші
ніколь над я люка адже коробова
аудит на та порошенка на януковича частіше
кувати в ряді ми робом у аудит
єврокомісії на скільки їжу папір був
ефективний результат іду за моїми
а підношу намотати і фінансової
петренко відсіку вони що україна
римується я kotova правда Європа урок та
тютикова не ви правда увійти аудиторій з
проаналізував його основні причини, ніж
у мавпи українки є результативний
маємо але словами а члени європейського
ринку ви і палати фоном на україни в тому
шукаю старовиною та олігархи контролю дядька
або сектори економіки і ви знаєте там
кулі таку голиму че реформи айкью як
боротьба з корупцією ключ у вас
нашої заспівав про це європа з карпенкова
палата ноут синьйоре ванька рубці україні
ми посилаємо усно transparency
international або а то даних ще
україна 1 знобит шкуру повних тримав
цьому я хочу українську і низку хочеш
[ __ ] і надійним партнером для моїх буднів
інтеграції в Європу травня ви вирішите цю
проблему ми визнаємо округ які вже
зрубані алла доводити б із корупцію
всі члени натомість не
ланцюги вперше світло європейського фатального
палату ще до україни за рік будучи тілу
дим вже за аналізом того я буду в тіла
не нинішній рекомендації аудитори
модемів плив на неї нові trunc і
фінансову піт ринку і на рішення
З тих же курортами виділені дві руки
тому перемогу допоміг обсі компу над 11
мільярдів євро на цьому уроки